Catedrática Tamar Gendler:
Bienvenidos al curso de "Filosofía"
y la Ciencia de la Naturaleza Humana.
Me da gusto ver tanta gente
hoy en la clase.
Espero volver a verlos el jueves.
Mi meta de hoy es darles
una visión general
de cómo será este curso
para que estén bien informados
y puedan decidir si quieren inscribirse
y obtener los créditos.
Teniendo esto en mente,
hay tres cosas que quiero
hacer en la clase de hoy.
En la primera parte de la
clase, solo voy a darles
una perspectiva general muy
amplia del curso
y hablaré un poco sobre mis
metas para este curso.
En la mayor parte de la
clase, voy a explicar
3 ejemplos del tipo de temas
que abordaremos este semestre,
para que se hagan una idea
del tipo de material
que vamos a tratar.
En la última parte de la
clase, hablaré un poco
sobre los aspectos
distintivos de este curso
y sus requisitos.
El curso tiene este nombre
desconcertante.
Se llama Filosofía y la Ciencia
de la Naturaleza Humana.
Está incluido en Filosofía y
en Ciencia Cognitiva,
y es un curso que otorga créditos
para la especialidad en Psicología.
¿Qué tipo de curso es?
En cierta manera, este curso es
como Estudios Dirigidos
en Filosofía o Filosofía 125 y 126.
Vamos a leer las obras de Platón,
Aristóteles, Epicteto,
Boecio, Hobbes, Hume y Mill.
Todos los grandes filósofos de la
tradición filosófica occidental.
Los vamos a leer desde el punto
de vista histórico,
con la intención de llegar
a algunas preguntas
a las que llegaríamos en un curso
tradicional de filosofía.
Además, veremos parte del material
que suele verse en un curso de ética.
Uno de los temas que vamos a
abordar en Filosofía
y la Ciencia de la Naturaleza Humana
son las 3 principales teorías éticas
en la tradición filosófica occidental.
Hablaremos del utilitarismo,
de la deontología,
de la ética de las virtudes
y veremos cómo se
relacionan unas con otras.
También veremos los
contenidos que verían
en un curso de introducción a
la filosofía política.
Estudiaremos brevemente la
obra de Thomas Hobbes
sobre la legitimidad del Estado.
Después, vamos a leer y
reflexionar sobre el debate entre
John Rawls y Robert Nozick
acerca de qué tanto peso
debería darse a los valores relativos
de la equidad por un lado y de
la libertad por el otro.
En ese aspecto, de cierta
manera, se trata de un curso
de filosofía estándar dentro de la
tradición política y moral.
No es un curso de metafísica,
ni de epistemología.
No hablaremos de temas
como el libre albedrío o del
problema mente-cuerpo,
aunque todos estos temas
podrían estar, sin duda,
dentro de la filosofía de la
naturaleza humana.
Este curso se distingue porque
analiza las contribuciones
hechas desde el aspecto
filosófico de la ecuación
y también desde una variedad
de otras disciplinas.
Uno de los principales temas
de este curso será
analizar cómo las cuestiones planteadas
por los filósofos
tradicionales, que ya he
mencionado,
se retoman en la tradición de la
ciencia cognitiva contemporánea.
En especial, cómo se retoman
en lo que percibo como
una de las principales corrientes
en la ciencia cognitiva contemporánea,
la corriente que mira la relación
entre los seres humanos
como criaturas racionales,
capaces de cierto tipo
de entendimiento reflexivo e
intencionado de sí mismos
y su lugar en el mundo, y,
por otra parte,
los seres humanos como
animales evolucionados
sujetos a fuerzas que van más
allá de su control racional.
En vista del reconocimiento de
que los seres humanos
son capaces de verse
afectados de varias maneras,
estudiaremos algunos
textos de psicología.
Leeremos algo de Freud;
discutiremos la terapia
cognitiva conductual;
hablaremos del trastorno por
estrés postraumático;
hablaremos de la felicidad,
usando un libro maravilloso
escrito por un exalumno de
Yale, Jonathan Haidt.
Estudiaremos algunos trabajos
sobre autorregulación,
amor y amistad, también
trabajos empíricos
sobre temas como
razonamiento moral y
castigo,
así como trabajos sociopsicológicos
sobre situaciones y actitudes.
Así que, gran parte del
material que abordaremos
en este curso viene de la psicología.
Aunque una parte también viene
de la tradición de la
ciencia política.
Durante la discusión de la
legitimidad del Estado,
nos adentraremos en la noción
del dilema del prisionero.
Abordaremos la tragedia de los comunes,
y en la parte final del curso,
hablaremos del papel de la retórica
y la argumentación en la
persuasión política.
También estudiaremos el campo
de la economía conductual.
Una de la tareas será
escuchar el discurso
del Premio Nobel, Daniel Kahneman,
cuando recibió el premio en su
nombre y el de su colaborador,
Amos Tversky, por su
extraordinario trabajo
al fundar la economía conductual.
También veremos otros trabajos
dentro de la tradición del
procesamiento doble y algunos pasajes
del maravilloso y conocido
libro de Dan Ariely
sobre economía conductual.
Por último, obtendremos un poco de
material incluso de la literatura.
Leeremos un breve pasaje de La Iliada;
un cuento de Ursula LeGuin;
y en la antepenúltima clase,
veremos qué dice Platón
sobre la forma en que la literatura y
la representación artística
afectan el
autoentendimiento de los
humanos.
En el curso, intentaré
unir estos 8 campos
para obtener una historia
coherente sobre
qué son los seres humanos
y cómo podemos estudiarlos
desde perspectivas variadas.
El eslogan de la estructura del
curso es hombre muerto
los martes y ciencia
cognitiva los jueves.
Aunque no todos los filósofos que
leeremos están muertos.
No todos son hombres.
Y no todos los otros campos
son ciencia cognitiva.
De hecho, muchos temas se van
a cubrir en conjunto
los martes y jueves.
Y habrá secciones. Aparte de
eso, el eslogan funciona.
Esa es la perspectiva general
del tipo de disciplinas
que contribuyen al curso.
Permítanme hablar un poco sobre
los temas específicos
que espero abordar en el
transcurso del semestre.
El primer tema global, y he organizado
el programa de estudios más o
menos bajo estos 3 temas,
aunque de cierta manera,
volverán a surgir a lo
largo del semestre.
El primer tema es la
felicidad y la prosperidad.
¿Qué dice la tradición
filosófica occidental
sobre qué necesita el ser
humano para prosperar
de manera significativa? ¿Cómo se
conecta eso con trabajos
recientes de diversas tradiciones
literarias y científicas sobre
qué es lo que permite
a los seres humanos prosperar?
¿Qué aspecto de la naturaleza
humana nos puede dar una
pista sobre lo que podría ser
la felicidad auténtica?
Esa es la primera serie de
preguntas que abordaremos.
Resulta que los filósofos de
la antigüedad pensaban
que los seres humanos
prosperan cuando sus almas
están bien ordenadas, por usar
la metáfora antigua.
Cuando las partes de sus almas
no van en distintas
direcciones y se encuentran en
una especie de armonía.
La idea antigua es que cuando eso pasa,
los seres humanos se
comportan moralmente.
La segunda parte del curso
abordará ambas cosas:
qué se siente desde el interior
comportarse de formas
que tradicionalmente se
consideran morales,
y desde un nivel superior, a
qué nos referimos
cuando decimos que una acción
es moral o inmoral.
Como ya he mencionado,
estudiaremos las 3 principales
concepciones filosóficas
occidentales sobre la moralidad
y también otras interesantes
cuestiones relacionadas.
Por ejemplo, ¿por qué a veces el
castigo es justificado?
¿Y la justificación del castigo
es psicológica o ética?
En la última unidad del
curso, pasaremos
del individuo a la sociedad en conjunto,
y analizaremos
qué hace legítimas a las
estructuras políticas y cómo
deberían organizarse el Estado o
las instituciones cívicas
para permitir que el ser
humano prospere.
Esos son los 3 principales
temas a tratar.
En el programa de estudios
que les he dado
están resaltados algunos ejemplos
de esos temas particulares
que abordaremos, en la página 1,
y hay una serie de preguntas
mucho más detalladas
en las páginas 3 y 4.
Además de estudiar el
contenido de estas cuestiones,
este curso los va a animar a pensar
sobre la metodología de cada
una de las disciplinas
que abordaremos. Mi meta es iniciarlos
en una serie de discusiones
filosóficas tradicionales
sobre la condición
humana, hacerlos pensar
en las cosas que tienen en
común estas discusiones
y por qué pensar las cosas
con el método filosófico
puede ser valioso para
responder a las cuestiones
que nos interesan.
Haremos algo muy parecido
con las otras disciplinas también.
Estudiaremos la literatura
desde la psicología,
la economía conductual, la ciencia
política y la literatura en sí,
y nos preguntaremos: ¿por qué
este enfoque distintivo
para responder a estas cuestiones
nos proporciona una visión
complementaria sobre los temas
planteados por los filósofos?
Finalmente, les pediré que
piensen no sólo en el contexto
de esta clase, sino en el contexto de
las otras clases que toman,
sobre la manera en que el
contenido al que se han expuesto
arroja luz a través de múltiples
perspectivas disciplinarias
sobre la serie de cuestiones
que nos interesan.
Eso fue la parte inicial de la clase.
La sección a la que he llamado
"perspectiva general y temas del curso".
Ahora, quiero darles 3 ejemplos
de los tipos de temas que vamos
a tratar este semestre.
El primer ejemplo está extraído
de las lecturas que
tenemos para el jueves.
Es un relato, de La República
de Platón, que se llama
"El anillo de Giges".
El jueves, les daré un poco
más de antecedentes
sobre cómo encaja este relato
en el contexto del libro
del que proviene, por ahora,
solo necesitan saber
que hay un personaje llamado Glaucón,
que de hecho es uno de los
hermanos de Platón,
el autor de este diálogo.
Glaucón está hablando
con Sócrates, el gran filósofo
griego de la antigüedad,
e intenta convencerlo de que las
personas actúan moralmente
solo porque no podrían salir bien
libradas si no lo hicieran.
Aunque solo hayan venido a
probar hoy la clase,
tendrán la oportunidad de
escuchar a Platón.
Les voy a leer en voz alta. Estos
números de la derecha,
se los explicaré en la siguiente clase,
se llaman números de Stephanus.
Sirven para encontrar el
mismo pasaje de Platón
en cualquier traducción que usen.
Voy a leer las páginas 359 y 360
de Stephanus. Entonces:
"Había una vez un pastor llamado Giges
al servicio del gobernante de Lidia.
Hubo una gran tormenta y un terremoto
abrió la tierra y creó un abismo
donde él estaba cuidando sus ovejas.
Al verlo, se asombró y
bajó por el abismo.
Ahí encontró un caballo
hueco de bronce.
El caballo tenía una especie de
aperturas y al mirar a través de ellas,
Giges vio un cadáver desnudo que
tenía un anillo de oro en su dedo.
Tomó el anillo y salió del abismo".
"Llevó el anillo a su
típica reunión mensual
en la que se informaba al rey
el estado del rebaño.
Mientras estaba sentado
entre los demás,
giró el engarce del anillo
hacia sí mismo,
a la palma de la mano.
Al hacerlo, se volvió invisible
para los que estaban a su lado
y ellos siguieron hablando como
si él no estuviera.
Estaba asombrado y jugando el
anillo con los dedos
lo volvió a girar hacia afuera
y se volvió visible.
Hizo varias pruebas con el
anillo para ver
si realmente tenía este
poder y vio que sí.
Si giraba el engarce hacia
adentro, se volvía invisible.
Si lo giraba hacia afuera,
volvía a ser visible".
"Cuando se dio cuenta de esto,
buscó la forma de convertirse
en uno de los mensajeros que iban
a dar el informe al rey.
Cuando llegó ahí, sedujo a la
reina y con su ayuda,
atacó y mató al rey, y se
quedó con el reino."
Esa es la historia del anillo de Giges.
¿Por qué narra Glaucón ese relato?
Glaucón cuenta ese relato con la
intención de que ustedes,
al escucharlo, piensen que
actuarían igual que Giges
si tuvieran la oportunidad de
salir librados del crimen
y no ser descubiertos.
La conclusión de Glaucón
es que aquellos
que actúan con justicia, en conformidad
con el código moral de su sociedad,
lo hacen porque no tienen el poder
de actuar injustamente.
Actúan así porque temen al
castigo de la sociedad.
No actúan así porque les
parezca valioso
de alguna manera.
La lectura que tenemos para
la clase del jueves
incluye también el texto que
rodea este relato.
La escena en la que
Glaucón plantea el reto,
del que se supone que esto es un
ejemplo, y la conversación
entre Glaucón y Sócrates que sigue
al planteamiento del reto
a través del relato. Además,
vamos a leer algunos trabajos de
psicología empírica
sobre qué hacen las
personas cuando piensan
que nadie las observa.
Así que nos vamos a
preguntar si, de hecho,
la gente podría, y si, de hecho,
la gente debería
comportarse igual que Giges.
Ese es el primer ejemplo
del tipo de temas
que vamos a tratar en este curso.
Una segunda serie de temas que
vamos a abordar en el curso,
parten de un ejemplo
filosófico en particular
que se ha vuelto muy popular
en las discusiones
contemporáneas de moralidad,
aunque es un caso que
apareció hace 40 años
en unos escritos de Philippa Foot y
la filósofa Judith Thomson.
En el caso, que supongo
que algunos ya conocen,
hay un tranvía que se dirige a toda
velocidad hacia 5 personas.
Si no se cambia su trayectoria,
chocará contra ellas.
La pregunta que plantean los filósofos
es la siguiente:
Supongamos que hay un botón
que se puede usar para
desviar el tranvía,
así en vez de chocar con 5 personas,
iría por otra vía y chocaría con una.
Cuando tengamos nuestros clickers,
podremos hacer esto científicamente.
Por ahora, quiero que levanten la mano.
¿Cuántos piensan que está
permitido moralmente
o que es necesario moralmente, es
decir, que no está prohibido,
desviar el tranvía para que choque
con una persona en vez de 5?
¿Cuántos piensan que está
permitido o que es necesario
desviar el tranvía para que solo
muera una persona en vez de 5?
[pausa]
Ok. ¿Cuántos piensan que
está prohibido moralmente
desviar el tranvía para que mate a
una persona en vez de 5?
¿Cuántos piensan que está
prohibido moralmente?
[pausa]
Ok. Como dije, no tenemos los clickers,
pero la mayor parte del grupo
piensa que está permitido
o que es necesario desviar el tranvía.
Bien, supongamos que la
situación es un poco distinta.
En vez de haber una
persona en las vías,
hay un puente encima de las vías.
Encima del puente, hay un hombre gordo
con una silueta tan ancha
que si lo dejaran caer,
usando el mismo botón que antes,
tendría el peso necesario para evitar
que el tranvía chocara
con las 5 personas.
¿Cuántos piensan que es
moralmente necesario
o que está permitido tirar al
hombre gordo del puente
para evitar que el tranvía
choque con las 5 personas?
[pausa]
¿Cuántos piensan que está
prohibido moralmente?
¿Hay manos levantadas otra vez?
[pausa]
Bien.
Esta vez, tenemos una
distribución muy distinta.
Ahora, supongamos que
terminamos en el hospital
y que las 5 personas que
estaban en las vías
cuando el tranvía no chocó con
ellas, están muy lesionadas:
una necesita un corazón,
una un pulmón,
una una pierna, una un
brazo y una un ojo.
Y entra un hombre sano que tiene justo
los órganos necesarios para
salvar a las 5 personas.
¿Cuántos piensan que es
moralmente necesario o que está
permitido cortarlo en pedazos para
salvar a las 5 personas?
[pausa]
No me voy a sentar con ustedes en la
sala de espera del hospital.
Hubo tres manos levantadas.
¿Cuántos piensan que está
prohibido moralmente?
[pausa]
Bien.
Supongamos que hay un oso
corriendo hacia ti.
Estás al inicio de una fila de gente y
hay un oso corriendo hacia ti.
¿Cuántos piensan que está
permitido moralmente quitarte
del camino del oso que está
corriendo hacia ti?
[pausa]
Ok. Si haces eso, el oso se va
a comer a la persona
que está detrás de ti. Ok.
Caso número dos:
Supongamos que hay un oso
corriendo hacia ti.
¿Cuántos piensan que está
moralmente permitido
tomar a la persona de atrás
y ponerla enfrente de ti para
protegerte del oso?
[pausa]
Hay una distribución de
manos muy diferente.
Ok. ¿Qué está pasando aquí?
En el caso original del botón
para desviar el tranvía,
morirá una persona si
desviamos el tranvía
y vivirán 5.
En el caso del hombre
gordo, si lo tiramos,
él morirá y 5 personas vivirán.
En el caso del paciente del hospital, lo
llevamos para cortarlo en trozos.
Una persona morirá y 5 vivirán.
En el caso del oso, si te quitas,
el oso irá contra la persona que está
atrás de ti. Ella muere y tú vives.
En el caso del oso, si tomas a
la persona de atrás
y la pones enfrente de ti para
usarla como escudo,
ella muere y tú vives.
Entonces, la segunda serie de temas
que vamos a abordar es:
¿Cómo se explican nuestras
diferentes reacciones en estos casos?
¿Existe una diferencia real
moralmente relevante
entre desviar el tranvía y aventar
al hombre gordo para que el tranvía
mate a una persona en vez de 5?
¿O la diferencia de nuestra reacción en
esos 2 casos es solo psicológica?
¿Existe de verdad una diferencia
moral entre agacharte,
para que el daño que se acerca a
ti llegue a alguien más,
y protegerte, de tal forma que el
daño que iba contra ti
caiga sobre alguien más?
¿Cómo se explican nuestras
diferentes reacciones en estos casos?
¿Qué implicaciones morales tienen?
¿Qué implicaciones
psicológicas tienen?
Esa es la segunda serie
de ejemplos sobre
los temas que vamos a tratar.
Tercera serie de ejemplos.
Me imagino que algunos
están familiarizados
con esta situación.
Van a la biblioteca con
toda la intención
de leer el texto de Platón
para la siguiente clase,
en cambio, se ponen a ver sus correos.
O se ponen a dieta
y deciden comer un montón de
frutas y verduras,
en cambio, se les antoja un pastel.
O deciden ahorrar para un
plan a largo plazo,
en cambio, se distraen con
la idea de pasar las
vacaciones en Jamaica con sus amigos,
o con la idea de comprar un iPod
o la nueva PlayStation 2
que les serviría para
descansar de sus lecturas.
¿Por qué los seres humanos
podemos hacer estos planes,
pero no actuamos para lograrlos?
¿Qué podemos hacer para
ceñirnos a los compromisos
que establecemos en los
momentos de reflexión?
La lectura que les dejé para hoy
es un capítulo muy breve del
popular libro de Dan Ariely.
Es un capítulo sobre la
procrastinación.
En él, Dan explica varias
estrategias que podemos usar
para ceñirnos a nuestros
compromisos a largo plazo.
Por ejemplo, algo que hacen las personas
que quieren leer es ir a la biblioteca
y rodearse de personas que
están leyendo.
Si estás en un entorno social
donde otras personas
se ajustan a un estándar al que
tú has decidido ajustarte,
es posible que te ajustes a
dicho estándar,
en lugar de hacer lo contrario y
después arrepentirte.
Si se te antoja mucho la comida que
tú mismo te has prohibido,
sería recomendable limitar tu
acceso a esa comida.
En el capítulo que leímos, Dan
Ariely describe un ejemplo
que él llama "la solución de la
tarjeta de crédito de hielo".
Si tienes la tendencia a hacer
compras impulsivas por Internet,
toma tu tarjeta de crédito,
ponla en un vaso de agua
y métela en el congelador.
Entonces, si quieres comprar algo,
saca tu tarjeta del congelador
y espera a que el hielo se derrita.
Si después de eso aún tienes
ganas de comprar, hazlo.
Restringir nuestro acceso
inmediato a las cosas tentadoras
es una forma de sortear el problema.
La tercera opción para sortear este
tipo de problemas consiste
en automatizar el comportamiento
que quieres fomentar.
Por ejemplo, si programo un sistema
en mi tarjeta de crédito
para que cada vez que gaste
10 USD otros 10 USD
vayan a mi cuenta de ahorros,
en vez de gastar dinero en lo
que voy a comprar,
ahorraré para los
compromisos que me he fijado.
La cuestión filosófica y
psicológica que se plantea
en esta parte del curso es la siguiente:
¿Qué seres son capaces,
simultáneamente, de
planear pensativamente
y no actuar de acuerdo con sus planes?
Se parecen mucho a las personas
de las que hablábamos en
nuestros 2 ejemplos anteriores.
Son seres que tienen un yo reflexivo,
capaz de razonar y comprometerse,
pero también tienen
aspectos de sí mismos que
no responden pensativamente a los
elementos del entorno.
Entonces, ¿qué estrategias
existen para ayudarlos
a ceñirse a sus planes que
aprueban pensativamente?
La respuesta básica es que hay
2 tipos de estrategias.
Una estrategia implica aumentar
la utilidad relativa
del compromiso reflexivo,
hacerlo más importante
para ti de cualquier forma.
Pensar que la lectura, el brócoli y las
alcancías son cosas valiosas.
La otra estrategia implica reducir
el atractivo de la tentación temporal:
reducir el acceso al correo
electrónico o a la comida,
o dificultar la
posibilidad de ir de
viaje.
Una cosa de la que
hablaremos en el curso,
tanto a pequeña como a gran escala,
es de la procrastinación como
punto de apoyo para entender
una gran cantidad de estructuras
sociales: leyes, códigos morales,
castigos, estrategias de
autorregulación, etc.
Todos estos son aspectos de la
sociedad que responden
a las dos estrategias
fundamentales que acabo de
describir.
Responden a cómo hacemos
que ciertas cosas,
que de manera reflexiva
aprobamos, sean más valiosas
o cómo hacemos que ciertas cosas,
que no desearíamos, sean
menos aceptables.
Ese es el tercer ejemplo
del tipo de temas
que abordaremos este semestre.
En estos últimos minutos
de la clase quiero
explicar algunos rasgos
distintivos del curso.
Primero, algunos ya habrán visto que
al fondo del salón está,
muy discretamente, un camarógrafo.
Está aquí porque
esta clase se está grabando para la
red de cursos de Open Yale.
Es probable
que sus voces sean grabadas en la cinta.
Si eso pasa, necesitaremos su
permiso para reproducir
sus voces en la versión para iTunes
University de esta clase.
Pero también es su oportunidad para
conseguir fama y fortuna.
Espero que el hecho de que este
curso sea parte de Open Yale
no sea un inconveniente,
pero si alguien tiene
cualquier duda al respecto,
dígamelo.
En segundo lugar, y lo más importante,
lo que distingue a este curso
es que de cierta manera es un
curso sobre sí mismo.
Los aspectos pedagógicos de este
curso están diseñados
con la visión fundamental que sustenta
todas las lecturas programadas.
Bajo esa reflexión,
asumo que todos ustedes se
comprometen a leer y aprender,
a interesarse en el material.
Mi meta es hacer que sea lo más fácil,
emocionante e interesante posible.
Habrán visto en el
programa de estudios,
quienes ya tuvieron
oportunidad de leerlo,
que hay tareas casi todas las semanas.
Estas tareas semanales están
diseñadas para despertarles
el interés en el material.
Por ejemplo, la primera tarea del curso,
descrita en la contraportada
de la carpeta azul,
les pregunta si quieren
comprometerse, voluntariamente,
a no tener acceso a Internet
durante esta clase
y tienen que explicar su decisión
haciendo referencia al texto
de procrastinación
que leímos para esta semana.
A lo largo del semestre, mi meta
será poner ejercicios
que los hagan participar de esa manera.
Uno de los ejercicios es escribir
una reseña de un cuento
desde la perspectiva de uno de los
filósofos que hemos estudiado.
Una de las tareas es diseñar
una semana de clases
para una versión futura de este curso.
Hay 10 tareas semanales, espero
que haciéndolas se mantengan
conectados con el curso.
De hecho, parte de las lecturas
del programa de estudios
son sugerencias de alumnos que tomaron
la versión para seminario de este
curso en años anteriores.
Además, como vieron en los
ejemplos del tranvía,
les iré pidiendo en la clase
que piensen sobre los
casos y los ejemplos.
Se ha descubierto que usar clickers
es muy útil para mantener la
participación de los alumnos.
La segunda parte de la tarea
de la siguiente semana
consiste en ir a la Biblioteca
Bass a solicitar un clicker,
si están inscritos en el
curso por créditos,
y registrar su número en la
página del curso.
Una vez que el curso se ponga en marcha,
a mitad de la segunda semana,
empezaremos a usar los clickers.
Por último, algo que
distingue a este curso es
que el año pasado trabajé en la
redacción del Yale Daily News
como estudiante de tiempo completo.
Tenía una beca de la Fundación
Mellon que me permitió
tomar clases, así que estuve la
mayor parte del año pasado
sentada en la última fila de
salones como este,
en clases como esta.
Así se me ocurrió la idea de apagar
el Internet en clase. Bueno.
Pero también me ayudó a
darme cuenta de
que el ritmo del semestre es complicado.
Como verán, la segunda oración
del artículo del Yale Daily News dice:
"Últimamente, sus calificaciones han
caído un poco: de un 'excelente'
en las primeras 2 tareas
a un 'entregado'
en los últimas 2".
Prometo que no publicaré sus
calificaciones en el Yale Daily News.
Pero, prometo que, como
resultado de esa experiencia,
soy plenamente consciente de
que organizar las tareas
con suficiente antelación
es vital para que
los alumnos tengan buenos
resultados en clase.
Por eso, he intentado ser muy
explícita en el programa de estudios.
Si miran las páginas 4 y
5 del programa,
verán que hay 5 tipos de
requisitos en este curso.
El primer requisito, y tal vez
el más importante,
son las lecturas que les he asignado.
Estas lecturas son de 2 tipos.
Aproximadamente la mitad
son de los 6 libros
que he pedido en su nombre
a Labyrinth Books.
Todos los libros tienen ediciones
económicas para estudiantes.
Todos se pueden conseguir
fácilmente de segunda mano.
Incluso comprando todos los libros
nuevos a precio normal,
costarían 80 USD.
Algunas tareas son de las
3 obras clásicas
que leeremos, Platón,
Aristóteles y Epicteto,
y de las 2 obras contemporáneas,
La hipótesis de la
felicidad de Jonathan Haidt
y Achilles in Vietnam de Jonathan Shay.
Por último, les pido que compren
un pequeño diccionario de
filosofía de 15 USD,
que es muy útil para buscar
términos y conceptos
con los que no estén familiarizados.
Sin embargo, sé que muchos
aún no habrán decidido
si tomarán el curso antes del jueves.
Y como la mitad de las lecturas para
el jueves son de este libro,
he puesto las páginas
correspondientes en el servidor
Classes*v2.
Así pueden cumplir con la
lectura del jueves
aunque no hayan comprado el libro.
Más o menos la mitad de las
lecturas son de esos libros.
Más o menos la mitad de las lecturas
son de artículos y esas lecturas
están disponibles en el servidor
*v2 para la siguiente clase.
Además de elegir libros
que considero adecuados e interesantes,
también he hecho el esfuerzo de
darles guías de lectura
para los libros, para que
tengan una orientación.
Si miran las primeras 3
páginas de la carpeta azul,
verán un ejemplo de una
guía de lectura,
y no solo eso,
sino que es la guía de
lectura para el jueves.
Verán que incluye 3 aspectos.
Primero, ofrece un poco de
antecedentes sobre el autor
y sobre el texto que vamos a leer.
Segundo, resalta los
términos y conceptos
que espero que obtengan del material.
Contiene nociones y términos
que te permitirán
expresar tus pensamientos
y el vocabulario
para entablar una
conversación con otros.
Por último, la guía de lectura
tiene una serie de preguntas
para centrar la atención a lo
largo de la lectura.
No es obligatorio que escriban sus
respuestas a estas preguntas.
Pueden usarlas para hacer sus apuntes
o para discutir con sus
compañeros de clase.
Para todas las lecturas obligatorias
tendrán esta guía completa
y para las lecturas
recomendadas y opcionales,
tendrán información del autor.
La segunda parte
importante de este curso
son las clases y las secciones.
Me gusta ver la clase tan llena
y me encantaría verla así
todo el semestre.
Prometo poner al menos una
diapositiva divertida
por clase o tal vez más.
En verdad espero que vengan [a clase],
porque cuando publico las
diapositivas [en el sitio del
curso],
no pueden ver la animación
del simpático pastor.
Intentaré hacer las
clases y las secciones
lo más atractivas posibles.
Haremos un esfuerzo para
que puedan realmente
interesarse en el material e
interactuar entre ustedes.
Me han informado que uno de los
horarios disponibles
para las secciones es los
jueves de 10:30 a 11:20,
en el mismo horario que la clase.
Evidentemente, es un error
tipográfico y agregaremos otros
horarios para las secciones a cambio.
El registro para las secciones se
hace de la forma tradicional.
Además, habrá 10
ejercicios breves dirigidos.
Ya les he hablado un poco de ellos,
en el programa hay
información de los puntos
que otorgan para la calificación final.
Hay 2 ensayos breves.
Habrá 3 temas designados y ustedes
pueden elegir 2 de ellos.
Por último, habrá un examen
final sobre la teoría
del curso. Voy a darles todas las
preguntas que pueden venir en el
examen con anticipación.
Les animaré para que
estudien el material
de forma centrada y estructurada.
El examen contendrá algunas de esas
preguntas que les daré
previamente para que las preparen.
Esa es la perspectiva general de lo
que planeo hacer este semestre.
Primero, el tipo de curso
del que se trata.
Segundo, los 3 ejemplos de
temas que vamos a abordar,
y tercero, algunos rasgos
distintivos del curso
y algunos de sus requisitos.
¿Tienen alguna pregunta? ¿Sí?
Alumno: [inaudible]
Catedrática Tamar
Gendler: La pregunta es:
¿Los videos de las clases
se van a publicar?
La respuesta es: los videos de las
clases tardan tiempo en
editarse y procesarse. Sí
se van a publicar,
pero no durante la clase.
Voy a publicar las
diapositivas de cada clase,
pero como ya se dieron cuenta,
las diapositivas no contienen
tanta información.
¿Sí?
Alumno: [inaudible]
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: No.
Todo en el curso se hace de
forma electrónica.
Todas las tareas se entregan
en el servidor Classes*v2, en
la sección de tareas.
La fecha de entrega del primer ejercicio
escrito es el próximo martes
a las 10 AM, pero como aún
estaremos en periodo de prueba,
lo podrán enviar sin
penalización hasta el viernes.
Todo lo de la clase,
en cuanto a envíos y
entrega de ejercicios
se hará en línea a través
de nuestro sitio v2.
¿Sí?
Alumno: ¿Cuándo
comenzarán las secciones?
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: ¿Cuándo
Las secciones comenzarán la
tercera semana del semestre.
¿Sí?
Alumno: [inaudible]
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Sí.
Vean el ejercicio dirigido de
muestra que les di,
está al reverso de la hoja azul.
Dice que los ejercicios
dirigidos valen de 1% a 7%.
¿Les diré cuánto vale cada
ejercicio dirigido?
Sí. Si miran detrás de la hoja azul,
verán que el ejercicio dirigido para la
siguiente semana tiene 2 partes.
Primera, sacar un clicker;
eso vale 1 punto.
Segunda, decirme si van a apagar el
Internet y por qué. 3 puntos.
Los ejercicios dirigidos
siempre indicarán
la pregunta y los puntos que vale.
¿Algo más?
De hecho, ya se nos acabó el tiempo.
Todos han programado sus
preguntas muy bien.
Espero verlos en la próxima clase.